We're now going to look at how to view and remove existing extensions.
To see information about the installed extensions available in your library, log in to Burp
Suite Enterprise as an administrator or an account that has been given permissions to
manage extensions.
From the settings menu, choose extensions.
To display the list of current extensions, select BAP extensions or custom extensions.
To see a description of an extension, click on the question mark for help.
To delete an extension, again, log in as an administrator or account with suitable permissions.
From the settings menu, choose extensions.
Click on the tab for the type of extension you want to delete.
And click on the trash icon next to the extension.
If you remove an extension whilst the scan that uses it is in progress, the scan continues
to use the extension until it finishes.
And click on the tab for the type of extension.
And click on the tab for the extension.